[Music
] Cristian Cásseres is in good health
with his own News Now program in
Spanish. There will be more noise than normal
near the Nellis air base in the
next few days. The members of the
air force will be carrying out
training exercises from Monday until  on
february 11 these exercises include
more than a dozen different types of
small planes they will also be flying
to the air base located in our
pegas the las vegas metropolitan police
are on the trail of a
suspect in a shooting at a compound
belonging to help  to ovi this happened
on saturday night when the
officers arrived at the scene they
found a person wounded by a gunshot
in the complex located on mails in
paraguay near flamingo street
now i tell you that all this according to the
police neither the victim nor the  suspect
are students the victim is
hospitalized and expected to
recover very soon one person is
dead and another hospital  after a
shooting on the outskirts of a
nightclub this happened on freeman
fences decision on Sunday
morning on the outskirts of the
establishment the two men
began to fight inside the place
then they continued on the street
being involved a shooting broke out two
men were injured  and they were
transferred to the hospital it is reported that
one of them died and the other is
expected to survive the authorities
are reviewing evidence from the place
meanwhile they ask for the help of
anyone who has more
information they are asked to call grand
software and we begin the  week with a
look at the temperatures we will have
a few nice days with temperatures
reaching 60 degrees for the afternoon
low in the 40s at night we have
some clouds to pass but this will not be
until friday I am cristian cásseres
with about english news neil
spanish good  day